- [Eddie] I think it's
really important to show
your true and authentic face to the world.
(upbeat music)
If you don't know who you are and
you're not presenting that to the world,
how are other people
gonna know who you are?
(upbeat music)
- I'm Eddie Jarel Jonesx
with an X on the end
and I am a member of the
Legendary House of Garcon
and I walk Butch Queen in Drags Runway.
(upbeat music)
- I walk, I eat, I slay,
I walk, I eat, I slay.
Judges, your score! Tens across the board!
- [Eddie] Makeup led me to being able to
explore my gender on my own terms.
Being non-binary is
literally going against
the gender construct that society has set.
For me, gender is like a shower nozzle,
where it's like you
have hot, you have cold,
and then you have everything in-between.
Nobody is all hot, nobody is all cold,
it's just what you've been allowed to
explore in your day-to-day life.
Makeup is like my armor.
For my daytime face, I don't
do like a triple-stacked lash.
That's for the Ball, that's for nighttime.
Makeup has always been
a tool in my community
for people to be the person they are or
who they really want to be and I think
that's the best way to sum up a Ball.
I can be this person in this Ballroom and
this is setting me up to be this person
out in the real world.
As open as the Ballroom community is,
many may think that gender roles are like
no big deal, which is
completely incorrect!
Every category has female
figure and male figure,
but that's not necessarily how I identify.
I've seen categories
like Androgynous Face,
that's a huge step towards breaking those
gender roles and I think it's really going
to be ground shaking.
I think in today's
world, there are way more
representations of all types of people
expressing themselves through
hair, beauty, and makeup.
And it just really helps children to see
there is someone else out there like you
and they're doing it.
That's really what my work is here to do.
(upbeat music)
- All right ladies and gentlemen,
this is the final battle!